there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right
so you only spend on things on your time
with things that are going wrong
wow you're all about that founders you
must be super good at
honestly most of us cannot find the jobs
early days
we're not that smart if i buy a device
and i
put in my desk drawer and never use it
then amazon doesn't deserve to make any
money
want to be happy build a life not just a
business
[Music]
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get the seven best
lessons from elon musk jeff
bezos and other billionaires enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one persevere with elon musk
how much of your success do you
attribute to
having really audacious goals or versus
um just not being focused on the short
term
you know money coming in or investors
unfortunately i i when one does have to
be focused on
the short term and money coming in when
creating a company because otherwise the
company will will die
so that the i think that a lot of times
people
think like creating companies
going to be fun i would say it's not
it's really not that fun i mean there
are periods of fun and
there are periods of where it's where
it's just awful
and particularly if you're the ceo of
the company
you actually have a distillation of all
the worst problems in the company
there's no point in spending your time
on things that are going right
so you only spend on things on your time
on things that are going wrong
and and there are things that are going
wrong that other people can't can't
take care of so you're like the worst
you have a filter for the crappest
problem
in the company the most pernicious and
painful problem
um so i wouldn't say it's it's i think
you have to feel
quite compelled to do it um
and have a fairly high pain threshold
and there's a friend of mine
who says like starting companies like
staring into your bus and
eating glass and there's some truth to
that
um the staring into the best part is
that you're going to be constantly
facing the
um extermination of the company uh
because
most startups fail it's like 90 percent
ugly 99 of startups fail
so i so you that that's the staring into
the abyss part you're
constantly saying okay if if if i don't
get this right the company will die
um it should be quite rightful quite
stressful
and and then the eating last part is
you've got you've got to do you've got
to do the problems you're going to
you're going to work on the problems
that the company needs you to work on
not the problems you want to work on
and so that that's you end up working on
problems that that you'd really wish you
weren't working on
and so that's the eating glass part um
and that goes on for a long time rule
number two be ready to learn with jack
ma
today the 18 founders of alibaba
a lot of people think they're legendary
something wow you all hibaba founders
you must be
super good at honestly most of us cannot
find
jobs early days we're not that smart
none of us graduate from a you know a
great university um
but the thing is that we are ready to
learn
we believe in the future if we work
together if we learn we
improve we'll be there i told them for
the first
year everybody forget about that you
will be vp vice president
right you will always be a tiny manager
in your life
because if we're successful people will
hide they will be smarter than us
if we only hire people who are stupid
than us then we'll be in trouble
right so when we hire people who are
smarter than us the company will grow
you will be happy because this is the
mission that we have
so i will say there's no best
people in the world that is suit ready
for you
the best of people is always you you
find the right people
working together training him developing
him and
he training you he then you have a
chance to build a team
rule number three align with customer
interests with jeff bezos
one of the unusual things that we do in
the kennel device business is we sell
our
hardware near break even and so we
make money when people use the device
not when they buy the device and that is
very aligning
with customers if i buy a device and i
put in my desk drawer and never use it
then amazon doesn't deserve to make any
money
likewise it causes us to have the right
kinds of
behaviors so for example if we're not
making money when people buy
the device then we don't need people to
be on the upgrade treadmill
uh they can we have people who are still
using five-year-old kindle ones and
we're perfectly happy about that
aws is very similar because it's a
pay-as-you-go
service we are not incented to get
people to
overbuy hardware to operate at low
utilization rates
our point of view on this is if we can
arrange
things in such a way that our interests
are aligned with our customers
then in the long term that will work out
really well
for customers and it'll work out really
well for amazon
lesson number four move with speed and
certainty with grant cardone
i had a guy the other day asked me for
some advice okay you know these people
that ask for advice i know you know
you give it to them and they they don't
do it yeah
he knew it was true it hit him he's like
i know that's right and then he went and
did something different
this is a big mistake people make man
things the best things that have
happened to me
did not require any more thought
the best decisions i've made in my life
were instant
so like my wife and i like when i've
decided to buy something i go buy it i
don't check with her
because that adds thought it adds time
and and this is another bad piece of
advice i was given like take time
think about it don't move too fast take
baby steps
uh you don't know nobody on this planet
ever took baby steps
they went fast and and the faster you
can go you know
my plane is safest when it's up in the
air when it's landing slowing down it's
in trouble when it's taken off
it's it's at risk that's interesting at
flight at full speed it's almost the
safest
thing wants to fly you know and and
people
people are being conditioned to slow
down think about it
take your time take a drug i was put on
lithium when i was 20
29 years old because the the
psychologist thought
i needed to slow down she was scared of
speed
i wasn't and at that time were you doing
well financially or
doing i was doing great but everybody
was saying hey you're doing too much of
this and you're doing too much of that
and you're going to burn and you're
going to do this
and people were worried about me around
me they were going slow i was vibrating
faster than they were
but a hummingbird vibrates bumblebees
vibrate
right they do things that are impossible
so
you don't want to slow down and and you
want to move with speed and certainty
that means people need to know what
they're doing
if i know what i'm doing that's why
confident people tiger won today
talking one today he's been fighting man
been efforting 10 years he hadn't had a
win he won today
that guy moves with speed and certainty
you know winners move with speed and
certainty because they practice they
train they educate
hey man how you doing buddy good how are
you you got a book coming out don't you
uh you just came out where can people
get it
get it on amazon easiest spot built to
serve
right there let's go man if you guys
don't know evan follow evan carmichael
he's got a new book out build a serve go
grab it today at amazon
there's a good dude right here rule
number five get on the right train with
warren buffett
if success is contingent on a good plan
excellent edu
um you know education and execution in a
driven mindset
what do you think makes businesses fall
apart
um when all of these factors have been
met
and con some businesses are just tough
i mean a significant percentage you know
the restaurants that
that open up this year are going to fail
i mean there are a lot of a lot of tough
businesses
uh i've always said if you want to be
regarded as a great business person
find a great business and
uh there's a huge difference i mean it
does make a difference
i i use this analogy when i when i got
out of columbia one of my best friends
was
terrific talent and uh
he went to work in the steel business
and
he did okay but it was the wrong
business to be in it's very important to
get on the right train
i mean you want to you want to get on a
train that's going to go 90 miles an
hour
and not one that's going to go 30 miles
an hour and you're going to try to
figure out how to you know
push it along a little faster so it
really does make a huge difference
uh and and there are some businesses
that are inherently uh there's far more
opportunity
and than others so you want to give a
lot of thought to what train you're
getting on
and uh i owned a half interest
when i was i don't know 21 or 22 in a
service station
uh a sinclair service station with a
palo mine in the national guard
it was a lousy business you know we had
a guy right next to us he kept selling
more
gallons of gas than we did he would cut
our prices and everything
i mean i i don't i don't care if you
know if you're a combination of steve
jobs and
larry ellison and everyone else you're
not going to succeed if you've got a guy
selling
gas below costs next year so you know
what it's important to get on the right
train
rule number six take a different
approach with sarah blakely
i think that there's um there's
you know traditional business has been
very masculine and it's been a very
masculine model and so i approach it i
mean and when i say that i
when i first started spanx i was maybe
three months in and i was at a cocktail
party and i
these three guys came up to me and they
said sarah so we heard you invented
something
and i said yes i did and they said great
and one guy you know pat me on the
shoulder and he said i hope you're ready
to go to war
and he said business is war and i just
remember looking at him and thinking
why and i went home that night and and
sat in my apartment and i sat on the
floor and i was thinking about all that
was happening and
you know um this risk i was taking and
potentially leaving my debt
job and the secure income and and just
thinking i don't want to go to war
and this voice inside of my head just
said do it different like take a totally
different approach
and so i have approached spanx with very
feminine principles and there's
there's the feminine and the masculine
in all of us and it's all super
important
but you know using vulnerability um
really operating off of intuition if the
data
is trumping my intuition i go with my
intuition
almost every time so you know that's not
typical in in a corporate environment so
those kinds of
things that i've done like being
vulnerable with the business
i am i felt as a consumer i i just felt
like
companies aren't really talking to me
the way that i want them to talk to me
i'm not listening to them i don't
believe them i don't necessarily trust
them
and so when i started spanx i um
instead of talking you know at
my customer i wanted to talk to them and
i
made myself vulnerable so i like i joked
and said i used my own butt in the
before and after picture
but i had felt like companies were
operating in this like
we need to be perfect and you need to
see us as the authority and
you need me and that's how i'm going to
sell you product
and i was like hey like i'm one of you
like here's here's what's happening
here's what it does for me
this is why it works and it was just a
very different
approach and i felt like consumers
became really connected and really loyal
and probably part of the reason why
spanx as a brand didn't need to
advertise for six
i mean for we haven't spent any money on
advertising in 16 years
because of a lot of it's word of mouth
from women sharing
with other women and rule number seven
the last one before a very special bonus
clip
is don't chase money with larry ellison
our goal was to get
we started with four employees uh and
our goal was to get to 50 employees
and the goal really was not so much to
make a lot of money i
wanted i wanted to me a lot of money in
those days was i want to own a house
i want to have a nice car and i wanted
to
work with interesting people and do
interesting things and i thought if i
could control my own environment have a
small consulting company
and oracle started out as a software
consulting company we work for tandem
computer if anyone remembers those guys
we work for ibm that we work for a lot
of uh
different tech companies in silicon
valley doing contract
programming fixed price contract
programming and we did pretty well
actually and and again the idea was just
to have a small
software contract software company uh
a bunch of you know we thought we were
hotshot programmers and we thought we
could make a decent living doing just
that
and quite by accident we built a product
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single
biggest takeaway from this video and
your plan of
action for the next week when you watch
a video and you just get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
got to take action
but when you get motivated and then you
create a specific plan of action for
when and how you're going to do it your
number jumps from 35
to 91 percent chance of following
through and when you commit to somebody
else
like posting down here in the comments
below that number jumps to 95
i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week
put it down the comments below so you
can follow through and i can celebrate
you
and you started out from my research as
a rapper am i right i did
okay so why were you uh inspired to be
in the music space
was that always something you loved to
do as a child uh yeah you know i grew up
in the 80s in in new york city in long
island
uh which was a focal point for rap when
i was starting out so i just got at an
early age
had a real interest in it and then when
i was in college
i made a demo tape and like most people
trying to get into the music business
in in college or in the late 80s i sent
out about a hundred
cassettes at the time it was cassettes
right to a
r executives to you know presidents of
labels i called
everybody and i got zero nothing
nothing callbacks so what was this what
year was this that was in 90
right all my college friends were doing
resumes and i was sending out cassettes
wow and that was my first real
experience with like pure
full-out rejection okay you need to get
rejected before then
not like not a hundred times in a row
right and um
but but it forced me to start to think
differently and figure out that you know
what
you really got to kind of differentiate
yourself and separate yourself
to get noticed and and get things done
right which which
ended up being a really valuable lesson
for me down the road
if you want seven more amazing lessons
from billionaire entrepreneurs check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there you should just be yourself
right i mean i take pride in the fact
that i didn't give it to what anybody
thought or said
i was just going to be myself i find if
i don't get enough sleep then i'm
i'm quite grumpy